and i am joined now
by not only one of the best analysts in
the business
one of the best guys charles i've never
heard someone say a bad word
about charles davis which by the way i'm
always a little skeptical of guys like
that right
like i know the bad things people can
say about me and they're probably true
but how can you be how can you live this
long and nobody says a bad thing about
the guy
charles davis does a terrific job for
cbs sports for nfl network he is
all over the draft charles it's ross
great to talk with you as always buddy
hey ross it's good to talk with you as
always as well and trust me on this
this not a bad word it's awfully kind of
you to say
you just haven't been hanging out in the
right place
all right so so charles in all sincerity
uh you know we can talk here there's
nobody listening
what is like if somebody had to say
something negative about you like if i
asked your wife like
or even yourself like what are your high
school buddies
what what would be the one thing they
would say you know
charles awesome bought this or that by
the way i met one of your high school
buddies one time
who told me you were by far the greatest
high school athlete from your hometown
oh is it dave ryan maybe wow you know
you know rhino
yes he told me he told me you were by
far the best high school athlete ever
from where you guys are from and upstate
but anyway what's the
what's the what's the one tiny little
charles davis flaw
oh i don't know that it's tiny and we
could go for a while but i'll give you
the one i can be a little negative you
know i i can go to
i can go to the word no a lot quicker
than i should
you know like someone will say hey why
don't we do and i don't want to do that
and i hadn't even thought about i just
immediately right to know
hey maybe we should consider nah we
shouldn't do that
and in retrospect after a little bit of
time
i might be the one that bounces through
and goes hey why don't we do such and
they're like we just said we should do
that
so i don't know if i said i want to make
it my idea i don't know what it is
maybe i'm just defensive that way but i
can be that way i can be a little bit on
the negative side
and i'm always on the lookout ross
for i even know how to say it the right
way
being wronged does that make sense and
and i'm not one of those who who is just
automatically hey
you're doing me wrong i mean i'm not
confronting people or whatever
i'm just making sure oh okay is is this
the right thing
and then half the time i walk away going
what was i doing why am i even why am i
even in that type of a space so
those are a few to get us started and i
feel like i should go to a couch right
now
on a cardigan have a pipe and you should
be nodding
while you're writing down your grocery
list and not listening to a word i'm
saying
you know what's funny by the way that's
actually a great question to ask
draft prospects on those zooms like
what's the worst
part about you mine is uh one of mine
is i have no patience like we went
skiing a couple weeks ago
and there was a line that was probably
like a five-minute line it wasn't that
bad
and i said to my brother-in-law i know
that this isn't a big deal
and i know that this shouldn't bother me
but i
am pissed off right now i hate this line
i hate it
i want to be on the lift and i want to
ski down right now
i don't want to be in this line lines
are for losers he's like just
it's good that you acknowledge that deep
breaths deep breaths so we all have
good well i will say this before you go
on that's an excellent question
and i wonder if we would put that to the
prospect's mother that plopped down in
front of the zoom and said she would be
answering the questions for her son did
you see that story no
yeah i just saw it i think i saw it last
night i'm not sure who broke it
who had it and i don't want to not give
them credit
but i also don't want to credit the
wrong person because in
in that business as you know you know
who got to that story first making sure
that the
proper people are credited i did read
this
that a team reported that when they went
to have the zoom with the prospect
mom sat down in the chair and said that
she would be answering the questions for
her
son wow so
we hear about helicopters we hear about
this in business world
where the parents show up at work to to
negotiate their kids race
to go over their performance reviews we
hear about all these things
this is you know look this is a new
world with zooms and all that
so why not but we've had we've had
parents be involved in stuff before
as a parent myself i've been you know
having to met with teaching having to
meet with teachers and coaches i hope
i've done it the right way
but we hear about these stories all the
time but this one
this is new talking with charles davis
nfl network
analyst cbs sports analyst he's all over
the draft
always every year you know we've totally
moved on
charles from the first two picks all
anybody cares about is number three
but i gotta ask you like are you sold on
zack wilson at two
are are you bought in on what the jets
are doing
i am and i bought and more so because i
bought in on zack wilson so i guess the
best way to answer it ross is whoever is
at two
and if they wanted zach wilson i would
be bought in on them
i really think that when you put him in
total
and you go through everything that
you've seen i see a toughness to this
kid that maybe he doesn't get credit for
having played through injuries for a
couple of seasons
thumb shoulder things that are really
going to affect the quarterback
he beat out a popular senior quarterback
and tanner mangum as a freshman to win
the job
and that's not easily done you know
because people like to gravitate towards
the older players especially at the
position like quarterback
and then to see him go all in get
healthy
and come back this year and have the
year that he had and we can talk
schedule we can talk this we can talk
that
i'm not having it i think the kid is the
legit item i like what i see from him
i'm not as concerned about the size as
some people are i think he'll be fine
going forward we've seen smaller
quarterbacks make it and make it big
i'm bought in with him because i think
the jets have a true plan going forward
on how they're going to do things so i
know the answer to this question charles
because you and i talked recently on my
podcast but i want people to hear from
you
you know we all know trevor lawrence is
the guy but you recently wrote
a story for nfl.com where you had the 17
guys you would pound the table for which
is
the expression they use when coaches or
gm say this guy is the man
you're a quarterback you say this guy
excites me the most when i think about
seeing how it all progresses
it's trey lance yeah from fcs north
dakota
why is he the quarterback that excites
you the most
he's the full combo of everything you're
looking for ross
size you know speed got the biggest arm
in the draft
now what that means to everyone i don't
know is that like a nolan ryan fastball
that he couldn't control earlier his
career
or is it the nolan ryan fastball later
you know it's all those things that go
into it
but all i know is this the kid is 17-0
16-0 and north dakota state has been
good for a long time and they've won
championships with easton stick
with with uh carson wentz with with
brock jensen who's one people might not
remember who who kept carson wentz on
the bench
so they know how to win but he had to
come up the same way and my comp for him
is josh allen
he and josh were both doubted coming out
of high school
both of them ended up at schools off the
beaten path
both of them were you know have been
plagued with the i don't know how
accurate he is i don't know if he
plays against good competition and we've
seen how josh has progressed
i hear about the the the brain the
football iq of trey lance he's the gym
rat that you want
and when i see him put it all together
i'm excited about watching this progress
and that's why
if i'm san francisco at three i'm taking
a good hard look at him fields and mac
jones before i make that final decision
especially if i'm keeping jimmy
garoppolo around if i've got garoppolo
sitting there and i can develop lance a
little bit
because i'll just leave it with this
ross normally when i draft a quarterback
in the top five he's starting for me
from day one
normally but with a kid coming out of
you know
one double a only one game last year
it wouldn't hurt at all if he had
someone in front of him for a little
while but if he gets trapped in the top
five it's not gonna last long you and i
know that
the person signing the checks is coming
to the office going yo
when's he gonna play that's how it works
when you have young quarterbacks
so it sounds like charles i don't put
words in your mouth but
if the niners pass on him at three it
sounds like you think the falcons should
take him at four
i think he'd be ideal to me it's the
perfect fit at four
because matt ryan's going to play and
you were talking you know and you made
you made some very nice statements about
me that i absolutely cherish ross and
i'm not saying that with tongue-in-cheek
it means a lot and you know for us as as
guys
dropping our veneers sometimes gets a
little difficult but i just want you to
know it really means a lot for you for
to me about what you said but think
about matt ryan
have we ever have we met a quarterback
in recent years that's his giving of
himself
as his pure heart a good teammate like a
matt ryan
so even if matt ryan's upset that you
draft the quarterback and every
quarterback that's a starter gets mad if
you draft another quarterback even in
the seventh round
he's going to take care of this young
man okay he's going to show him the
right example
he's going to teach him all those things
he's going to tell him look you need to
observe and watch i'm not going to
hand it to you but he's also not going
to shy away from questions extra film
sessions all of those things what a
great way to break in
plus an offense that is already you know
been productive and somewhat ready to
roll so
i would love that fit for him if he were
to go to atlanta and have a year of matt
ryan
because i think after that atlanta would
be ready to really start
the arthur smith regime and maybe matt
ryan's looking for a place with a
contender
to finish out his career we'll see i
don't know all right wrapping up here
with charles davis from nfl network all
right let's play that out then charles
let's say the falcons do that
and take trey lance at four then
cincinnati has their pick of
jamar chase penney sewell or
kyle pitts who a lot of people feel like
is the best player in the draft
let's say you are duke tobin or you are
a player for the bengals
whatever yep which one of those three
guys are you
pounding the table for if the bengals
have all the options all the
non-quarterback options at five
well i'm old school so i'd wanna go
ahead and immediately say tackle to
protect my to protect joe burrow and
anthony munoz has already signed off on
that
but i look at this draft and i think
that i can come back in the top of the
second round and get a pretty darn good
tackle again
i don't know if i'm passing on kyle
pitts tight ends are young quarterbacks
best friends
they they absolutely love them they're
writing their sight lines the throws are
easy i'm doing the joey trivia air
quotes because nothing's
easy in the nfl but those are the ones
that get out of your hands quicker get
to the guy and he turns it upfield and
pits is the kind of guy who makes big
plays for you
so it's going to be very difficult for
me to pass on him although i have to say
ross every year we go into this and we
always have the buzz words and the buzz
phrases and i can speak them as well as
anyone right you can speak football i
can speak football and sometimes we
drive ourselves crazy doing it
but the word this year to me is
generational i don't know about you but
i'm hearing generational used way more
than i've heard in the past
trevor lawrence is one of those
generational quarterbacks kyle pitts is
a generational talent
and to me what that means is he's really
good
and maybe the best one in the draft you
should go get him we'll find out if
they're generational based on their
career and i'm not saying it as a
negative
even though you as i told you i can get
that way it's just funny how
we indoctrinate all those things and
they become part of the lexicon we used
to say a guy threw the ball really well
now we say he has arm talent i mean it's
just
just how it works well and the best part
about the generational thing
is two things number one it reminds me
what's that what movie is that where the
guy says
i don't think that word means what you
think it means princess bride maybe
princess bride
i do not think that word means what you
think it means and that's number one and
number two
generational we literally had
back-to-back generational pass rushers
nick boasts of the one year and then
chase young the next year
i don't think you know what generational
means charles davis the nicest guy
in the world and a terrific analyst
thank you so much man really appreciate
it
ross always a pleasure to spend time
with you thanks for having me on
continued success i look forward to
seeing you in person again real soon
absolutely cannot wait there he is
charles davis